what's up everyone we are back at
blockchain for social justice we are now
seeing down David Rob alright man thank
you for coming on the show my pleasure
really appreciate it
global ambassador for unified Earth
that's correct yeah
so tell us a bit about your path and
like how the hell did you end up at
unified on earth well I am a mental
health and economic development educator
by education and my my birth as a being
was the Epiphany while I was an
undergrad at Berkeley about 35 years ago
but there's no mental health education
in the American school system there's
one counselor for every 479 students
there's about a thousand students per
counselor in California and I realized
that it would be pretty hard for us to
assume that our young people could
become worthy human capital they don't
even know they're intelligent they don't
know why they're in school they don't
know why they feel compelled to drink
smoke join gangs are killed I wanted to
find a way to reach the populations not
through the schools themselves so I
looked at alternative means by which to
reach you know our young people and that
led me to movies television and later on
games VR etc etc and in order to follow
that path I had to take my own path
because there was no job that could get
me to where I wanted to be so instead of
getting a job and I was offered my first
job at Microsoft in 1985 I help people
start companies for about 35 years at
the same time I pursued my mission of
producing content my first big movie was
a movie called a lawnmower man I had to
produce all the display graphics and
that and I was the main VR consultant
that was an early hypercard producer at
Apple as a consultant in the mid 80s and
I've produced games for rock bands I
worked with BB King and queens Reich
Peter Gabriel a little bit with you too
a bunch of folks and that periodically
did things with Microsoft over the years
I helped bring the second city comedy
troupe to MSN
in the mid-90s I guess it was and
fast-forward got recruited into being
incoming executive preferred the Steve
Jobs movie with Ashton Kutcher about
maybe seven or eight years ago that
brought me a number of other movie
projects they're all social impact I'm
only interested in doing things that
have social impact and my other life is
supporting myself because movies don't
really do that unless you're in the
studio system or more logically a
distributor because that's where most of
the money goes or disappears depending
on your perspective and I have continued
to help people start companies over the
years I was working over the last year
and a half also with two UN foundations
UN facing foundations one of them is UN
g-sii dot org dedicated to measuring the
degree to which the world's thousand
largest corporations do or do not deploy
the 17 sustainable development goals
which were the goals of the UN launched
and had every world leaders sign but to
in 2007 and 2015 17 goals of 169 sub
goals that would actually make the
achievement of the SDGs clean water
education gender equality sustainability
collaboration basically 17 metrics and
169 sub goals measurable so that we can
actually begin to chart where we are in
terms of converting the world to what it
really should be which I consider the
world heaven we just don't know it and
you know our world is a beautiful place
and we're all beautiful people except
those marred by fear challenges from
childhood that caused them to become
pathological or greedy or insensitive to
others narcissistic and I believe that
mental health is the missing piece yes
so I got pulled into black chain
initially I was recruited about a year
ago into a crypto startup which I said
no to I was then recruited into a hedge
equipped a hedge fund in the fall last
year has to help them raise funds didn't
really get engaged until November of
2017 when I was recruited into a Chinese
idv company called that key dot VIP they
attempted on a 60 million dollar pre ICO
over four months and in two months they
raised over a hundred million dollars
which they kept about 83 million and
that was quite a ride for me I did it as
much to learn and then several months
ago I got a call from a dear and most
amazing friend of mine in 30 years he's
been called by the New York Times the
Jerry Maguire of Silicon Valley
he took Hollywood managed Hollywood
agent protocols and techniques and
became the number one technology agent
in Silicon Valley had between seven and
eight hundred at the top computer
scientists in the business and his
people did little projects like Mac OS
Microsoft Word Acrobat etrade little
projects thought about 900 of them I
think he retired to pretty well for
himself about 10 years ago came back its
last summer wanting to do something
really big for the world but doing
something that was within the purview of
his skill sets as resources and mostly
his commitment to good as a hippie from
the 60s one of the founders of the of
the organic food movement and that was
blockchain who is this famous bow
Renaldi boa and all of a and very
interesting fellow who super bright and
super committed to social good and you
know the redistribution of the resources
and the wealth and the opportunity and
the capacity for all of us to have a
chance to be human to have our lives and
and have quality of life and to manifest
our dreams and most importantly my
perspective as a mental health educator
to realize our brilliance our
contribution of the planet blockchain is
an amazing palette when it comes to
visualizing where he-man
can go because it has contracts that
define all the transactions that define
all the exchanges all the data
transmission and when you have contracts
versus people mediating resources wealth
etc etc you can begin to gain trust in
interactions and transactions and people
and gain trust that you will be you will
be compensated for your IP or your value
etc etc and the decentralized aspect the
immutability of it the mutability you
can't change a contract from the past
you can always change it going forward
the immutability the security although
security is not actually a hallmark of
blockchain today but it will be
increasingly so there are so many hacks
of the blockchain right now that never
get announced I had two friends one
friend a friend and one friend that have
revealed major hacks to themselves in
the last week alone that never gets
reported most of the code for blockchain
from what I understand and from those
that I trust tends to be somewhat
undocumented they call it some people
call it spaghetti and it was I haven't
put together by people that are
opportunistic one and find a way to ride
the Bitcoin wave through these other
block chains that we're growing and but
this is just the early days okay let's
let's go back because I think we can
even come to more about blockchain as we
talk about unified earth but maybe
before we get there we have to go all
the way back to mental health I was born
a rich white child in Connecticut and
that's some steam art in the joke I just
get it backwards this is really
important these like you you came in to
joking around like I loved your energy
you have really funny jokes and puns and
it's just it's just good vibes you know
you make people laugh I love that so
there were two things that you mentioned
at the beginning that we have to unpack
before we get to blockchain your life
trajectory has been very interesting and
so let's unpack that first thing is
mental health so mental health is
crucial to talk about and they
and it's not being taught in school to
the degree that it needs to be in order
for kids to be living healthy and happy
lives especially with the onset of the
social media fabric that's now kind of
added into our social fabric now
tell us more about your passion about
mental health and exactly what we can do
moving forward with mental health mental
health was not my my life mission for my
young life I didn't really have much of
a mission like most people other than to
as I grew into my teens and started
reading a lot I began to aspire to be
spiritual and to create my own
structured meaning by which to
understand life that's baitul high and
bail I'm Maslow type philosophy I
suppose I believe that each of us has a
purpose for being here as a mission as a
unique contribution of the planet but so
few of us were taught that I was lucky
enough to get into Berkeley and meet a
professor who liked me and invited me
into her office one day and she asked me
a question which all of you reading this
or listen to this video should ask
yourself which is we have a million
dollars in the bank and you could do
anything what would you do I told her I
would make movies because I made a movie
when I was 15 in high school and I liked
that but what I would really probably
want to do is to teach because I love
what happens to people's pupils the way
they dilate and we have an epiphany or
you realize you're intelligent or god
forbid you realize your purpose because
I believe yeah every human being is a
genius assisant Moses will never know it
and therefore never manifest it because
society doesn't teach us that and she
looked at me and said if you don't do
both those things you don't have
integrity hmm so I took a degree in
rhetoric which is the technology of
language and degree in film which was
the chosen language combine the two
studied the Soviet propagandist
filmmakers the wove together the Soviet
Union from 150 tribes and from 15
countries into a single culture
by virtue of the power of their new form
of narratives capacity that trick the
brain and to believe in what you're
seeing is real and therefore to process
it as a for nature kind of reminds me
about the Edward Bernays a little bit
right which which of his work are you
talking about you're talking about the
various movies are doing about a style
of filmmaking one yeah yeah and the
manipulation of the using psychoanalysis
to get to people
yeah that's ability to replicate
realities that cause what's called a
suspension of disbelief is very powerful
and so you studied Soviet propaganda and
then you were told that you had to
withhold your integrity of going into
teaching in film and I'm really how we
know that how you didn't that's not
correct okay I started the Soviet
propaganda filmmakers wrote a manual
called a prescription to an educational
cinema for American high school teachers
in K through 12 teachers to produce far
more compelling history videos math
videos etc using Soviet propaganda
techniques so it's sort of the opposite
interests lying
so via Soviet propaganda techniques for
the good for the good yeah and I got a
very good grade on my thesis was my
honors thesis at Berkeley and I was told
it was a failure and I was confused by
that I didn't understand why they would
give me a good grade and tell me I did
it wrong this is what you did very well
in your film theory or semiotics etc you
didn't do it quite as well in the
education part of your thesis but
education was not what they taught us in
fact they said we presume that you learn
what you learn from a couple books in
the library which is true so I said what
did I do wrong and they said well
there's five ways that people learn
motor skills verbal skills harder
thinking symbolic learning and what was
then called social-emotional learning
I'm sorry attitudinal learning today
it's called bio psychosocial literacy
nobody ever calls it what it really is
which is mental health
mmm-hmm and I realize at the moment that
how how could we possibly expect our
young people our human capital to become
deployable as valuable assets when kids
don't even know they're smart they're
not even taught that they're intelligent
nobody told you that when you're in
school nobody knows why they're in
school they don't know why their parents
fight or get divorced they don't know
where aren't their they don't know why
they feel compelled to drink Smok join
gangs or kill so i with that epiphany I
committed my life to delivering mental
health and economic development
education through to youth populations
of all ages awesome and using movies
because we didn't have games that this
is in the early 80s yeah and I realized
quickly that nobody would finance my
kind of games or my kind of movies
rather so I had to learn how to raise
money I raised half the billion I have a
million dollars for the Berlitz language
videos co raise that and I was recruited
into a company that was doing something
called multi-threaded bivariate
operating systems which I asked what
that was and they go well some people
are calling it Windows so I got pulled
into technology and entrepreneurship
because of that and so I have always
carried the torch of mental health
education through all my activities in
technology and retainment education we
BAC got a master's in education using
virtual environments to model family
therapy that was in the late eighties
and that activity in the VR space got me
a gig on a Movie Club a lawnmower man
which is the first PR movie is a Stephen
King short story based on a sheet
Stephen King short story and I did I was
the main VR consultant I produced all
the display graphics all the graphics on
the computers in the in the movie that
led me to EMI North America where I
wrote all the digital downloading
strategy for the board that I start
producing games for rock bands and I've
just had a very interesting long life
with mental health as the driving theme
but survival and later on you know
taking care of my family it's a big part
of that and
you're on it's a very complex and
beautiful 35 years that you've had of
doing this different work and especially
with the theme of mental health being at
the center of it
I really appreciated your example of
taking these strengths in Russian
propaganda and helping us with the
educational system the mental health
educational system and I'm happy that
even through people telling you that
this sucks this that it was great in
these aspects and it sucked and this one
that you persevered and you stayed with
it and you took what you could and roll
through the next thing that you
mentioned after men thought that I
thought it'd be important to unpack was
the sustainable development goals and
your there's your ties to the U u NGS
IIgs Islands sustainable goals index
initiative Institute excuse me you and
animals un hei sustainable goals
indexing Texas Institute so now now this
is really important because you are
measuring how well the top 1000
companies in the world actually
ultimately everybody but founders I'm
not a founder decided to this was born
when the SDGs were born in 2015 as a far
more granular and ultimately measurable
metric for for measuring the grid which
the world does evolve itself along the
17 metrics which are clean water or food
you know good education gender equality
there's a list of them but so the
question would be how the hell are you
actually measuring how well the
corporation does know the UN g-sii does
it un jia side or or does it they have
about a hundred or so analysts read all
the major newspapers they read the the k
ones and and the annual reports for all
these major corporations and they
measure things like mentions of the SDGs
mentions of of specific campaigns and
activities basically all of the
mentions either intentionally or non
intentionally and build profiles from
there and then they work with other
companies that do other types of
measurement as well in terms of data or
in terms of men you know in terms of
actual deployments etcetera etc so
they're aggregating data and they're and
they're interpreting it with respect to
the profile of these thousand Laurence
companies they're actually they've
actually profiled about 300 and so far
and 100 of them now between 17 and 18
and they send somebody in to do with the
investigation now they do it through the
media through the media this is plan
sorry a new report k1 and the world's
largest newspapers Times post number of
the Frankfurter Zeitung
and the Beijing you know except I'm
really excited to see exactly what comes
out of the analysis of the thousand and
then also how we can help motivate the
ones that are not following through on
their involvement because their
involvement is so crucial because they
have so much geopolitical sway in the UN
statement so here's their strategy what
they're doing is they're building an
index by which you could invest up until
now people that had consciousness or
appreciate that sustainable corporations
actually do better than other
corporations would do something called
negative screening they would say I
don't want any money in tobacco I don't
want any money in alcohol or any money
weapons it's called negative screening
which leaves a myriad number of
companies what this index allows is
what's called positive screening I want
to invest in the number one company in
the world in water sustainability I want
to Destin the number one company in the
world doing gender equality and that's
good I like that so with it but here's
the point the more that this index shows
that yeah the ark and the financial
success of the company and this is what
it's showing to me better than the S&P
you know better than the average the
more that the large pension funds a
growing number of which want to make
conscious investments that's great we'll
choose sustainable companies over not
sustainable companies meaning those that
do not
embrace the SDGs will find themselves
without access to the lifeblood of money
that is crazy cool and interesting
anyone that's focused on greed or power
or Orleans floods on those things they
naturally gravitate to them out of
compensations for challenges they had or
have or just the default to capitalism
which is honor the maximization of the
value for the shareholders at the
expense of other considerations which
might make a more successful company in
a more level playing field but it's
myopic it's not system centric it's my
hope it's myopic and system centric
would mean the whole earth view and
issue a customer base you don't wanna
deplete all the capital out of your
customer base that can't be your
customer anymore and you will literally
go extinct if you don't start pushing
towards sustainability start pushing
towards the interests of the customers
started Atrus of the world interests of
sustaining and prospering that's very
interesting the direction we're going
right now if we don't act and especially
cool that the number one company in this
aspect of sustainability or this aspect
sustainability and that's gonna be
really interesting to be able to see and
some hairs them I would love to see that
and learn about it and then bring on
other people to talk about that I would
love to do that and I'd love to talk
more about mental health as well and the
differences between mental health for
someone of a high socioeconomic status
versus a low socioeconomic status then
surprised about how similar - purse
orders for the different classes yeah
for example the rich is so much easier
to get sucked into jewelry and and all
the crazy materialistic possessions and
the low SES they don't even have a buddy
wants your money it's very lonely this
love aside depression a lot of addiction
I mean it's I'm doing this concert
hopefully in November the first major
global concert to address mental health
and as a major societal challenge that's
not been addressed and where is the
concert attentively at the Nova Theatre
in Los Angeles and 2nd of November and
on a 1st November at the Grammys Grammy
Foundation cool
damn we would love to come do interviews
at that event it's not impossible you
hear that everyone help us out on
patreon help us get down there we really
need to get down there and do interviews
so bad okay
that is good I'm really happy that
you're doing that
thank you that's gonna be a phenomenal
place no I mean yeah I'm working with a
former Assistant Secretary of Education
and the music director for the five
presidents concert in Houston which
raised about 40 million for hurricane
relief Freeston yeah I'm ready to to
push over some of the eggs in our
baskets into the mental health basket so
I wanna that's hot 30% increase in
teenage suicide in the last 12 months 23
school shootings in the last six months
that's a no health issue yeah yeah and I
want to also push some eggs into the
analysis of the 1000 companies and how
well they're doing with their SDGs UN
g-sii United Nations Global suspend
because it's nothing of nations it's you
I'm facing oh your Institute UN GSI I
don't work global sustainability index
initiative okay how about a little bit
more about this understanding of
Epiphanes yeah we have time time limited
time limited quickly if Anita and
epiphany is a life changing in son Jason
Silva initially inspired me with the
Epiphany knowledge as well about it's
like you were saying when you teach in
the pupils open up and there is that
epiphany the mind never goes back to
those old dimensions that it was in so
my consulting firms what has been called
epiphany partners and my film company my
film fund whatever you want to call it
is called a Tiffany Film Fund and all
the things I've done I've always been
about education through entertainment
and technology so I want to facilitate
as many epiphanies as I can
facilitating as many epiphanies as you
can I know another organization the
Sikhi 12 foundation the amazing
educational content that's free for
everybody across planet that we really
get to plug in some mental health work
into that as well to have more
epiphanies up for everyone around the
world last bit here on unified earth
unified on earth what is the elevator
pitch for it it's the world's first 3.0
blockchain framework fastest we believe
the most secure the most extensible
meaning aii OT geofencing etc etc and it
was designed by people that basically
helped build Silicon Valley did almost a
thousand major projects Microsoft Word
Mac OS what I mean by did by his I had
talent on those teams and are dedicating
Silicon Valley class computer science
engineering etc to building the
framework upon which social impact
centric business commerce education
entertainment philanthropy can exploit
the true value and the original and
stated value of the blockchain to help
bring humanity back to where we really
should be which is having a high quality
of life
celebrating our humanity and mostly
manifesting our gifts to the world and
to each other and to the spirits which
brought us here yes it was a really
beautiful way to put it maximizing human
potential to its fullest in each
individual and the collective
now why would I go ahead and build on
top of your platform rather than
implement the blockchain technologies
within my organization I know it costs
more probably more money to implement it
within my organization that are what to
just build on some idea why would you
use work with us versus do it
autonomously or do it a birdie Theory in
the now or - or whatever yeah because we
have taken a look at all the major
foundations made over almost a thousand
engineering fixes and literally applied
Silicon Valley class programming
documentation architecture
etc to building the platform by which we
can we can make a difference so it's
much easier to use
it's totally extensible it's it's
completely documented and and and we're
a platform upon which numerous types of
crypto transactions and Senna programs
even icos
can and will be manifest we're opening
our first launch our first exchange in
the Bahamas on the 8th of the 8th month
of the 18th year of this oh sorry in
July cool and weird valleys aligned
which is probably the most important
thing congratulations thank you
click power round of questions first
question is are you concerned about
wealth inequality being exacerbated by
exponential technology of course I am
it's gonna go in one of two ways either
it's gonna go the way it normally does
which is out of fear the aggregated
aggregation of wealth at the expense of
you know the ecology known as humanity
or or there would be explicit re
distribution and wealth in a very
organic and natural way by which people
will be honored for the value and
brilliance they have and they will be
given greater access to the kinds of
education they need to operate in 21st
and then 22nd century education economy
I have a 10 year old so I think about
this a lot
yeah it really depends on who's behind
the wheels when it comes to things like
blockchain AI yes you know the big five
yeah now in terms of globalization how
do we balance the we are one mentality
with geopolitical leadership well
geopolitical leadership typically
reflects nation-state ideology or
geopolitical harmonization for the UN so
it really depends on where you are I
believe that that whereas Shanghai and
Beijing used to be a war New York and
Boston used to be war the world with
tribal
and you you couldn't go more than a mile
or two from your cave and face fear I
believe that slowly but surely over the
last couple hundred thousand years
humanity is becoming closer and closer
which is why there's such revolution in
the area of constitutional expression
and protection of Rights because we are
coming together as a species I'm a big
fan of Star Trek yeah I love the
Federation yeah that both honors
individuals and cultural identity yes
and at the same time exploits the power
of diversity when it comes to skills
intelligence or you know however you
want to parse humanity so I'm a big fan
of us coming together but not at the
expense of freedom for anybody and
everybody to realize their dreams and
total purpose do you think we're alone
in the cosmos not at all okay which
cosmos you're talking about there are
many cosmos if you tell my alien life is
that when you're talking about our
cosmos our universe are we alone in our
universe and our universe to me it's
mathematically incomprehensible that
there aren't other planets out there
that have the stuff to create the
chemical reactions from which life
happened now did those other species
managed to survive the very debacles
that we are now experiencing as human
beings which we're closer to nuclear
annihilation than we've ever been
and yet there's also more Hope than
we've ever had because the tools are
being spread consciousness is being
shared and I do believe that the that
humanity is bifurcating into those that
feel empowered to make a difference and
those that are empowered but don't want
to make that happen yet they'll wake up
to that and must have psychotic and and
then of course they're the others that
haven't woken up yet and that's my job
as an educator among numerous other
educators likewise and then do you think
we're in a simulation red pill green
blue pill I'm into the green pill what's
the green pill green pill is bio mental
sustainability it's my favorite color
whether or not we're in simulation it
does not matter in the least because
from our perspective this particular
level of reality and I produce games and
I understand some of the implications of
simulation we love that analogy to this
level of realities yeah it doesn't
really matter from simulation certainly
you know our reality is nothing more
than the aggregation of data inputs on
our synapse no concretize into
behavioral perspectives and patterns of
recognition which allow us to form react
and identities and interface with other
identities and you have hopefully
formulate something called consciousness
which is awareness of our capacity and
our place in the greater universe far
beyond being a human and again whether
it's a simulation or not doesn't matter
it's a good thought experiment expands
our minds to newer realms of
consciousness and diversity of thought
around the cost and immortality basis on
a more healthy basis ok very last
question what is the most beautiful
thing in the world the truth why because
you know what when you see it and it's
in all of us and is that an is that a
truth of the individual essence and a
different truth for the collective
essence are they the same truth what a
what a weights getting at truth is
authenticity
truth is the the core meaning of any
expression identity being physical self
but what's not pretty is deception
what's not pretty is subterfuge what's
not pretty is you know the manipulation
of others at the expense of the
possibilities for Humanity and this is
what you're working on with unify earth
and so much more sustainable development
goals mental health thank you very much
for teaching us about all of this David
I really hope to make really strong
connections with our above between our
networks and what we're trying to
execute an impact on the world my
pleasure man thank you for coming on the
show everyone if you had a good time
please give us a comment below with your
thoughts also subscribe and join us also
take the video content that you just
watch don't just consume but go create
with it going make a video about it go
write about it tell to people about what
you learn and they'll tell to people and
let's keep spreading this
message around also join us on patreon
so we can continue coming a great place
like this and highlighting really
brilliant people thank you for joining
us in the show and we'll talk more soon
bye
you